why are limitations on films that's
actually a good thing in your mind
because that is what brings up
creativity having limitations on a film
set
brings out creativity because when
you're sort of stuck by these boxes
whether they're financial or you know
location based or time based the best
stuff really really comes out of you
like you're able to think of things that
maybe you wouldn't have you know if you
had all the resources in the world it
can be over indulgent but when you don't
have any resources then you really have
to get crafty and that's when the most
and the purest creativity comes out and
what I've found is that things are much
better when there are rules and sort of
borders that you have to sort of work
your way around versus you can do
anything so you know you end up you know
potentially with nothing that's true
like maybe a cool backdrop but then the
story suffers with broken ceiling
you had one location you had it for four
days you had all your actors there you
knew like you didn't have to really
change locations were there other
limitations within that within that
office building where you were shooting
that really lends itself to the story I
think you know we had a little bit of
free rein of that office which was great
it was just the limitation of time was
something that everybody runs into but
for us you know we had like a monitor
sitting there going like like you have
to be out by a certain time you know you
can't go over this so that was something
that you know kept us going because it's
like we only have this much time in the
day you know we're gonna shoot for maybe
10 12 hours but like that's it we can't
keep shooting we can't go over like we
don't have that luxury so with the time
constraint you know that was very
motivating and and helped everybody in
plus you know
the story itself had just lended itself
to that because I wanted them to feel
like they were in a high-pressure
situation so the fact that we were in
reality in a high-pressure situation
really really helped you know get that
feeling on the actors because they're on
a conference call on a Sunday mm-hmm and
they all have to kind of go and face
each other yeah interesting and how many
pages did you do a day I think the most
we ever did in one day was about 60
pages oh wow
which is insane and unheard of if we did
like you know between 80 and 90 setups
which is crazy but again totally doable
because we didn't have to move lights
you know using the all natural lighting
but yeah like we we were definitely
cranking through and getting it and you
know it's it's a tough thing to do when
you're in a conference room for the
majority of your running time you just I
remember thinking how do I make sure
that people aren't bored because that's
the most important thing because it can
be so easy so like visually I have these
four walls right those are the
parameters like what can I do to really
make this one looking just look
interesting but make sure that it really
gets across what the characters were
going through visually which was a hard
thing to do but but something I think we
were able to accomplish did you do a lot
of close-ups then of just like eye
movement or like how did you yeah it was
a variation of not using too much you
know close-ups but when it was necessary
using that using movement when the
moment or the scene called for it you
know there's a specific moment that I
can recall where you've got Ken you know
the boss sitting in the center of the
conference room and then you've got
Tyler and and Garrett on the sides and
they're sort of going back and forth you
know like sniping at each other so it's
like if you have three of them right
here how do I make this dynamic and
interesting and show the interplay
between the characters so what I came up
with is having the camera throw
from character to character and sort of
a one-take so you know we would have
Tyler say something and then we would
wit pin it over to Garrett who would say
something we would go back and then we
would go to Ken and then back and forth
so you go oh they are you know volleying
off of each other almost plain of verbal
tennis you know so you see that and that
would play so much more different had I
decided to do just the standard you know
like single shot here single shot
they're cutting back and forth to really
like grounded in one shot and move it
back and forth gave it much more of a
sense of energy and a connectedness that
I don't think you know just standard
sort of coming back and forth would have
done did the actors know that at one
point you would do sixty pages in one
day of your four days shoes oh no of
course but it's just what we were able
to do which was great I let him know
that we were gonna be shooting a lot and
we had to get a lot done but I even I
didn't think that we were gonna shoot
that much like I didn't plan for like
let's do sixty pages like that's insane
I was like okay let's we got to get at
least twenty maybe thirty you know four
days we'll stitch together ninety
minutes but but we were just in it you
know and and they were down for it and
they wanted to keep going and you know
it was exciting because everybody was
sort of pushing towards that same goal
of like let's get this done and because
you know the the fact that they're all
stuck in this room together
and sort of like at each other's throats
it's like it absolutely helped that we
were just barreling it through it
because it didn't give them time to
think or reflect back on online readings
or performances like they were really in
the moment which is what was necessary
for it and I think we got the best
performances out of it because of that
constant sort of like striving and
pushing when day four came toward the
end of the day how are those last few
hours and then when when they finally
said okay it's time like how are you
loading the truck well what's that like
sure there were no trucks didn't have
money for trucks okay it was a Camry
what
yeah floated up into the car and do that
and like find some place to throw out
trash that was interesting the fact that
you know at this location like we had to
bring trash bags and we had to take the
trash with us so trying to figure out in
Los Angeles where what where can I
legally throw away trash was something
that we had to do that I had to do you
know after each shooting day so just
another thing that a director has to do
is drive around with trash in their back
seat and throw it out at some place but
could you take it to the dump no no we
felt like some open you know trash bins
[Laughter]
which other the four days on broken
ceiling was the 60 page 60 pages a with
that that was the second day the second
day was the one that we did the 60 pages
I think the first day we did around 30
and then the second day we did around
around 60 or so and yeah it's funny
because we did so much stuff like that
first weekend and then I was able to go
back and just you know I had a full week
to sort of look at the footage and I
started editing right away and I found
certain things that we had missed or
that we didn't get or that you know
there was like a boom shadow in some of
the shots and like stuff that on the day
like we hadn't caught so it was it was
super invaluable and I'm so glad that we
split it up into two chunks because I
was able to look at everything and go
okay like we actually need to reshoot
this and we need you know pick up with
that and we got to do this so when the
next weekend came around I had built in
you know into the shooting schedule all
of these things that we had to to sort
of reshoot which was an interesting
challenge but everybody you know sort of
rose up to that but then on the the sort
of final days and the final day
specifically it was down to all of the
Karen Kendrick stuff you know for her
character Angela because she there's a
thread through the movie where she's
sort of you know we see her on her own
which is very interesting and very fun
in cinematic because we got to venture
outside of the car
room and sort of travel you know
throughout other parts of the office and
it was cool because everybody else was
sort of gone that day it was actually I
think it was Father's Day or it was one
of the holidays where a couple of crew
members were like I couldn't can't make
it you know I think we we lost our
script supervisor or whatever on that
Dame one of her producers but it was
alright because it was mostly like non
dialogue based he was more visual so it
was cool and because we got to shoot the
final shot of the movie as sort of the
last thing that we actually shot so it
was nice you know anyway it was calming
after all of that you know long dialogue
and work to sort of spend a day shooting
non dialogue based visual stuff it was
cool at the end of the day the for four
days did a representative from the
building come up and be like okay guys
this is it I mean we gotta wrap this up
or how does that work for that we had a
monitor that was kind of there the whole
time so yeah there wasn't no like you
know you guys got to wrap it up by that
time we knew that like we have to go but
it was cool in that like the last day we
didn't shoot the full amount it was a
little bit of a shorter day so we left a
little bit early and it was still you
know he was still sunny out the Sun was
actually coming down you know Magic Hour
was it was pretty good and it was very
emotional I remember it and this is
something that for some reason and maybe
it's just the way that I handle you know
being done with a shoot but I remember
you know going to my car you know the
car with a bunch of trash bags and the
trunk and and and I drove home and I sat
there in the garage and I took about I
don't know maybe five ten minutes and I
just sort of like started crying like
happy tears happy that we had done it
sort of relieved that we had done it but
just so grateful that everybody had
jumped in to do this crazy thing she did
in a feature film in four days
shooting 60 pages in one day like that's
insane
but everybody hopped on board and they
did it and just like it was all the
emotions of like gratitude and
thankfulness that came out and yeah it
was it was a great feeling and again one
of those feelings that that I love to
have and that's why I'm still you know
making films
you